the American middle class is full of
whiny selfish morons that's right I said
it so folks recently I've been getting a
lot of hate mail complaining about one
topic in particular - steven crowder hey
face how about you stop acting like a
mouthpiece for the Republican Party for
a day and start talking about what
really matters the shrinking middle
class we've built this country
tirelessly and selflessly only to be
trampled by the big corporations that
you and your Johnny Bravo need well
looking ahead to support so you think
you've pulled them all over the eyes of
old Hank huh well I've had enough of you
you see that you just gave me a small
heart attack you selfish [ __ ] but I
wouldn't expect a silver spoon
namby-pamby Cadillac health care plan
smart like you to understand big oil I
tell you this the middle class will rise
again and it will be signed Hey - Hank
folks I don't think there is a myth more
falsely perpetuated in America than that
of the disappearing middle class and I
say this as a middle-class American one
who's shot edited and distributed this
video to you with my very own
inexpensive equipment and you're most
likely watching this on your personal
computer or smartphone with noise
cancelling headphones let's rewind just
a few years ago if you were the
wealthiest person on the planet you had
nothing anywhere near as cool as an
iPhone 15 years before that you wouldn't
be watching this on your own personal
computer then let's rewind 80 years
we're even if you were the monopoly guy
you live in a house without air
conditioning television your precious
Starbucks or the myriad other amenities
that we take for granted and that's if
you live long enough to not be taken out
by a common virus or disease that are
now easily managed
to modern medicine that's why people had
so many kids back then they didn't know
who make it nine would get sick and four
would get kicked by a horse or something
now all of these things have been
brought to you courtesy of the free
enterprise system now I just want to
tell you about a conversation I had the
other day and no I'm not exaggerating oh
my god is that an iPhone 4G yeah yeah
this that's so friggin nice yeah you
know I'm actually pretty grateful for it
it's coming pretty handy for me that's
so cool I mean all I have is this 3GS I
guess it's nice cuz I have unlimited
crayon but I mean too slow and sometimes
be a crappy service and I really want
the 4G okay thinking that after my
boyfriend got it a lock up then I might
get the 4G it's so much nicer so much
faster you have HD that's 30 good no
this is actually this is just the 16 gig
I didn't really need this oh my god Liz
that I have dug the xxx egg because I
didn't have on my tunes on there you
know I'm so much music see the middle
class is not shrinking well actually it
might be in a sense because earners of
over $100,000 a year have actually
increased from 12% to over 20% since
1979 so in fact a lot of the middle
class are actually moving into upper
class not lower see the real problem
here is that the middle class in America
today are ungrateful and today's
politicians are all too willing to
pander to our selfish nature I want to
get a car but I can't afford it don't
worry we'll hook you up cash for
clunkers I keep building a crappy
product that nobody wants don't worry
we'll bail you out I want to live in
this house but I can't afford it
we'll take care you Fannie Mae Freddie
Mac well the average household income
has decreased over the last decades when
you adjust for inflation
yeah but individual people earn anywhere
from 44 to 62% more because the size of
the average household has decreased
dramatically
Thomas Sol is brilliant on this Rita
stuff my point is that when you look at
the big picture historically the middle
class has benefited immensely from the
free enterprise system by any measurable
barometer and if you sincerely want to
screw the middle class please oh please
give the government more of your
hard-earned money there any gig for up
to me
you get no gift you cannot get 30 gigs
you wouldn't get 16 and you deserve no
gigs because you are of no benefit to
humanity or society whatsoever and you
know what your boyfriend please lock up
they would stay in lockup if I had my
way permanently in lockup if only to
punish you because you are a drain on
society collectively as a whole what are
you doing ah no nothing
your funny hair bye